Welcome.
Welcome in to Market takes look.
First of all,
a Happy Nuggets 2023 NBA championship day to those
of you who celebrate out there.
I know I'm celebrating Denver Nuggets 2023 NBA champs.
But of course,
that's about yesterday.
And today we are looking into the C P I consumer price index reports here
on market takes.
I am Dion Bowen reporter at the Wall Street Journal.
We are going to dive into this data,
but don't forget Denver Nuggets are 2023 NBA champions.
Uh Listen,
this morning's C P I report was a big one.
Um It's got a lot of folks in the markets excited,
especially on the risk asset side.
We're going to break down what it means,
what the data said,
what this tells us going forward.
We're going to talk about what the report showed how it compared to expectations.
Of course,
how this sets up the Federal Reserve because as we know everything moves the way the fed
moves,
we're gonna take a look at those markets,
tell you about how they're responding,
talk about the biggest takeaways from this report and what comes next.
So first of all.
Let's throw up here on your screen,
this chart showing what's going on with C P I.
Now,
as you see there,
we have seen 11 straight months of decline in the year,
over year consumer price index.
That means inflation has been slowing every single month since we had that peak of 9% in
June.
That's that big tall bar.
You see there over in your screen about the middle of 2022.
Um Ever since then,
we've seen inflation consistently come down.
And then today we got a 4% reading inflation rising 4% year over year.
Well below that 9% number and below those 5% and 4.9%
that we've had the past couple months.
So again,
that acceleration in declining or the acceleration or decelerating,
uh inflation rate continues,
that's bull for risk,
bullish for risk assets.
We want to throw another chart up here on your screen.
Now,
this is core consumer price in,
that's not quite as bullish as you see.
They're holding up above 5%.
The reading for this month was 5.3%.
So core inflation hasn't been coming down that same nice wave pattern that we saw
for overall C P I.
You're seeing the core C P I really a little bit more stubborn,
holding up a little bit higher and not just illustrating that some pieces of this
inflation story are not moving the way the Federal Reserve would like them to.
So this is something that's why markets I think were very excited when this data first came out
4% right on the numbers right in line with expectations.
The month over month change was just 0.1%.
This was an exciting,
exciting report for the market.
But then you saw,
oh,
wait,
hold on,
let's look at that core number and you started to see a little bit of change in the market.
So that's what we're seeing right now.
Overall,
there were some worries as we came into this report,
we had seen new home sales jump last month to the highest since March 2022.
We had seen purchasing managers indexes showing uh business activity starting to rebound
the highest in a number of months.
We've seen services be a major concern for the fed retail sales last month
unexpectedly picked up.
So there were all things to suggest that consumers were still going out spending that maybe inflation could be
higher.
But as we saw in the report today,
4% year over year.
Well down continuing a string of declining lower C P I
numbers and and C P I uh increases or increases in inflation.
What were the biggest contributors to this report?
Well,
we saw shelter gas and used cars uh being the biggest things holding
and the biggest things moving inflation higher.
Now those all matter because one,
what do we know about shelter,
shelter has been consistently coming down according to real time measures of the economy.
But we know that C P I Shelter gets fed in on a lag.
So even though the shelter index is rising consistently,
that's based on older data,
the real time data tells us that shelter costs are coming down.
What do we know about gas?
We know gas is very volatile,
it moves up and down significantly.
So when you get a big spike up in gas or a big move down in gas,
uh gass actually moved down significantly.
But we know that that is not uh one of the major pieces that the Federal Reserve
looks at because it's not something they can really control,
that's more controlled by OPEC global oil demand,
things like that.
That's not something that can uh really attack or bring down.
And what's that other piece used cars?
Well,
that's goods and we know that goods prices have been well below overall inflation coming down
much faster than the overall pace of inflation.
So when they picked up this month,
well,
that's going against the trend and that suggests that maybe that's not something to be that worried about.
So all the things that really would need to be moving in the right
direction are in these things are moving in the wrong direction,
namely use cars and shelter,
real time measures of the economy tells us that those aren't really things that we need to be worried about.
And those are things that in terms of the overall trend are moving in favor of inflation
coming back down.
So big picture inflation continues to cool,
continues to come down.
But it's being held up by a couple of things that could go away.
You don't really know they're not things the Federal Reserve controls,
but you also have to look at that core inflation and say,
OK,
well,
that's mostly being held up by goods,
but it's staying around the same level.
It's not coming down the way we'd want it to um Ronald Temple.
He is the chief market strategist at Lazard.
He's uh an investor there.
Chief Market strategist,
he had an interesting quote.
I want to read it to you really quickly.
He said,
quote another month of core C P I over 40 basis points is disturbing on the
surface but used cars and auto insurance drove nearly half the
increase this month.
More importantly,
shelter inflation remained at a substantially lower level than recent peak levels and will continue
to accelerate while other services inflation was contained.
Overall,
the fed should feel com should feel comfortable with the pause at tomorrow's meeting and it's tightening
appears to be working on the stickiest drivers of inflation.
So that is good news because we don't,
we know investors don't want the fed to keep tightening rates,
don't want the fed to keep raising rates higher,
making it more difficult for businesses to go out and borrow money more expensive to borrow money.
Making those credit card rates rise higher,
making those personal loan rates rise higher.
Those home equity lines of credit and home equity loans rise higher,
get more expensive.
Uh those things all slow down the economy,
make people less likely to spend the market doesn't want that.
The market wants folks spending that money and,
and going out there and doing those things.
Speaking of,
let's check in on the market right now.
I wanna put up here on your screen,
the the latest data that we're seeing what we're seeing from the market.
Now,
you saw the dow after the report came out just really take off like a rocket ship.
We are seeing a bit of moderation.
You're seeing the S and P 500 kind of coming down a little bit.
And the NASDAQ,
you see not quite as much exuberance as what we're seeing there from the dow,
but all up about half a percent on the day.
I think the really interesting uh response to this is in the bond market there.
What you're seeing on your screen here,
this data is the 10 year yield,
that's the most traded treasury.
And you're seeing it just take off and spike up higher,
going up to 3.8,
5% about five basis points today.
But that is a big move for the 10 year note.
You're seeing the same thing on the seven year note.
Look at this,
these long dated bonds,
you're seeing just a big pick up and take off.
Now,
when we go to short dated bonds,
you're seeing just the opposite.
You're seeing those numbers come down,
the two year uh spiking back up.
But you see the one year,
the six month,
the three month,
all those bonds that are really correlated to what the Federal Reserve is going to do and what's gonna
happen right now in the near term future,
those are coming way down.
Investors saying we want to buy bonds,
we think yields are coming down,
inflation coming down in the short term.
But when you look at this 10 year number,
that big spike that suggests that maybe the Federal Reserve not doing as much is
got investors a little spooked about what that could mean for the future of inflation and what that could mean for
inflation longer term.
So that's definitely something you want to watch out for.
And we look over here at currencies,
you're seeing the euro up a little bit really,
it took off after that C P I data was released and you see a big spike higher,
but it's kind of come back down after that.
Uh really currency is not seeing a big move after this.
I think the move here in crypto is interesting because you're still seeing Bitcoin again right after that report was
released.
Bitcoin took off,
but it's coming back down.
A lot of that bullish enthusiasm that was in markets has come off now and we're
seeing markets kind of come down.
So really those numbers just illustrating the overall market reaction
markets really getting bullish and excited after that report came out.
4% percent oh down,
right on the numbers.
But you know what,
uh when we look at that core number,
when we really dig into the report,
maybe there's not as much to be excited about.
And also,
as we know,
stocks and risk assets have really rallied over the past week or so,
maybe,
you know,
this is a bit of uh buy the rumor,
sell the news when we got the news C P I came in as expected.
And markets are saying,
all right,
maybe it's not that much to be excited about.
But let's break down what we can expect after this report from the Federal
Reserve.
So the Federal Reserve widely expected to pause as in the fed has been raising rates
ever since March 2022.
The expectation coming into this meeting before we got this data or any other or a lot of data uh for
this week was that they were going to say,
hey,
let's take a,
let's take a step back.
Let's breathe.
Let's see the effect of what we've already done before we go about raising rates
anymore.
Well,
this report with inflation C P I inflation coming in at 4% really backs the case that
definitely pauses the right move and maybe going forward,
we don't need to raise rates anymore,
maybe going forward,
we can just,
you know,
back off and,
and maybe even start cutting rates,
which is what the market really wants and market has been pricing it.
So initially very bullish for risk assets.
But that core number again,
putting a bit of a pin in that,
uh,
the fed expected to hold rates according to fed funds futures at this June meeting,
but then expected to raise rates in July.
And interestingly,
I thought with this kind of bullish C P I number,
you would see the expectations for that July rate increase to really come all the way off.
But you're not seeing that investors still expecting the fed to raise rates next month,
which I think is very interesting.
So a lot is gonna hinge on what we hear from Fed chair,
Jerome Powell at this meeting.
A lot is gonna hinge on what we see from the summary of economic projections that we get from the
Fed.
And you know,
this is again,
the fed is still expected to raise rates next month,
about 60% chance priced in the fed funds futures market.
So investors saying,
ok,
this C P I report says that you pause in June but then you still raise in July and then what is
that set up for the rest of the year?
And we're gonna have to get clarification on that from the fed and we're really not going to know.
So I think tomorrow's Fed meeting is obviously going to be highly watched.
It's going to be very important,
what we hear the chairman say and what we see from the other FED members in terms of how they're viewing
markets.
And I think that could potentially start setting us up for a very big
Blockbuster July report depending on how this other data comes in,
what the fed says will be very important in terms of how the market reads and what we can expect to
see from the market going through for the rest of this year.
So the biggest takeaway from this report again,
we see inflation continuing to come down.
You see that 4% number well below more than half,
uh or less than half of what it was in June and about halfway to the fed's 2%
target.
Again,
the fed's target is 2% inflation.
Uh And we're about halfway there more than halfway there because we were at 9% back in June of
2022.
So as we sit here in June of 2023 as the Fed has already started
their meeting,
they've kicked it off and they're talking about this report right now,
just like I'm talking to you guys about it right here.
They're saying,
OK,
what does this mean for us?
And they're looking at that core C P I number,
they're looking at that overall C P I number.
They're looking at the month over month change and they're saying the folks who were in the camp of,
we need to pause.
They are probably,
you know,
feeling really good about their position right now.
Folks who said,
no,
we need to keep raising rates who would come out and,
and really actively campaign for that.
They're probably kind of ok.
Well,
maybe I'll be quiet right now.
I'll be quiet,
but we'll see how the rest of the data comes out.
So again,
tomorrow's retail sales report is also gonna be very important.
Um And you're gonna wanna or sorry,
not tomorrow.
Thursday's retail sales report is gonna be important,
but we know that the big market mover is going to be tomorrow.
The Federal Reserve report,
the statement comes out at two PM.
Then we hear from the chairman at 2 30 we will be right here on market takes at four after the
market closes to tell you all about what happened at that fed meeting what the chairman
said,
break down what he said,
what he didn't say what was in the statement and why it matters.
So we'll be doing that all here tomorrow at four o'clock.
I hope you'll join us.
We also,
like I said,
get retail sales on Thursday and then next week's housing data I think is gonna be very big.
Again as the shelter component has continue to hold up inflation if we can
start to see continued deceleration and declines in some of these existing home
sales numbers.
If new,
if new home sales start to pull back again and move lower,
that could really be bullish for the markets.
And again,
I think this market could have legs because the data is starting to support a lot of this
bullishness and enthusiasm that's in the markets that's already been priced in the stock prices.
So,
you know,
we could see that.
Uh next week is Juneteenth.
Uh Happy June 10th.
We are gonna be out on Monday.
We will be back here on Tuesday to give you that report.
So stick with us on Market takes,
man.
We will be coming to you with all the information that you need.
Uh That's gonna about wrap it up for us.
But again,
tomorrow four o'clock PM,
we'll be breaking down that fed meeting right here.
Hope you'll join us.
Listen,
I'm Dion Rabo reporter for the Wall Street Journal.
That's it for this edition of Market Takes.
I hope that you'll be with us next time.